your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a mid a DA
Center this Center this mid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
[Music]
more how are you guys doing I'm joined
with two very esteemed gentlemen here to
my left one known for academic prowess
and intellectual debate and the other
known for
um for his fantastic
contribution to humankind Theology of
cck I was I was going to say that uh
today we're going to be talking about
sprinkle sprinkle
who's who's been on Tik Tok and and
who's been on Instagram and I've seen
some of her videos actually some of them
are very long but I've seen them and
I've actually read I've been reading not
just now but I have been reading because
the part of my work is to discover about
feminism and that's actually modern
trends of it and permutations of it and
so on and so I I read some what what
people call dark fem literature oh yeah
okay which what I give you an example of
that is a book that was written by uh
Agro called why men love
actually it's one of the it was a
bestseller and um it's what you'll find
in what this woman says here and we're
going to go through some of it is I
wouldn't say a copy and paste of that
but it's very similar to the kind of
principles you read in that book uh and
also you could say and she has been
dubbed this a kind of reverse of the red
pill movement so it's like people have
called her the Andrew Tate the female
Andrew Tate some people have compared it
to Kevin Samuels uh it's the same kind
of thing using the if you like the
Robert Green 48 Laws of Power
you know explicitly using them sometimes
in the context of a relationship so I
wanted to just um first of all before we
start with the reaction get your opinion
on this Al because you've been dealing
with these things uh actually on the
ground in the Muslim Community wh why do
you think some Muslim sisters in
particular cuz I did see the comment
section and some of it didn't have lots
of Muslims commenting why do you think
anyone would gravitate to this I mean
it's just opposite of the red P movement
I think there's a deep hatred towards
men as well this this for variety of
reasons but yeah I mean at the end of
the day you know like um my wife came
across vide I was watching it with her
once and it was just it just funny cuz I
was just like looking at and thinking
like sadly there's so many um I wish
call it vulnerable misguided individuals
who could just watch this and because
they've had a bad experience with men
and now they go to the other spectrum of
you know they've become hostile because
the way she talks is like she's she
actually she I don't think she looks at
men as a human it's like you know what
what can I use him for transaction
transaction how can I manipulate him you
know and it's like just imagine if that
was on the other side which the red PE
do which were against as Islam we're
trying to be balanced here so yeah you
can see the dangers of that because the
marriage marital unit is already under
attack and now this is added on to it
and um sadly it goes back to again with
our sisters who are following this kind
of narrative it's it's a lack of in
Allah and that's some woman who says
sprinkle sprinkle is going to give you
some advice and then you're going to try
to implement it it's going to backfire
and you're going to suffer more so it's
sad but I mean we can go into it more by
hearing it okay and so Bora you've read
all of Robert Green's Works uh when
we're going through this um this
particular these clips and stuff I think
you've read every single book isn't it I
haven't been through all of it stuff but
one thing I can say is it smells exactly
like that I think it's explicit it's
explicitly that so look it it's
instrumental it's mellian it's very
clearly dependent upon the consequences
you're going to get not the ethics or
the values or the morals that you want
in a relationship exactly let's take a
look at the first clip maybe and then
come back and resp in kind when a woman
can walk away from a man and dismiss
them like this that makes the man want
them more that's why I tell y'all to
ghost men sometimes because when you
ghost a
man and they can't figure it out it's
like why do she ghost me I was you know
it's because a lot of times
um when someone gets too comfortable and
too attached and too um whatever their
value goes down as as you know as
special as the prize okay so let me
respond to this first and then get you
guys' opinion the first thing I want to
kind of delineate here are two things
here you first you have an ethical
consideration and then you have if you
want a strategic consideration right so
the ethical consideration we consider
like you've mentioned before it's unver
virtuous really it's not virtuous action
for you to come into a relationship
especially from our perspective as
religious men people that believe in
Islam uh into a relationship with this
kind of transactional quality like okay
what can I get from him let me try and
get him to basically try and manipulate
him Etc and so on and so forth however
for the sake of argument if you like
let's actually think about what she's
saying from a strategic perspective
let's assume that whoever's listening to
this whether it's a Muslim woman or
non-muslim woman doesn't care about
those virtuous considerations or those
ethical considerations I would say that
there's actually no evidence for what
she's saying because what she's making
is essentially a psychological point
right now she's B basically saying that
if a woman is more dismissive in a
romantic relationship to put it in
academic pance she's saying if a woman
is more dismissive to a man in a
romantic setting that he is more likely
to be attached to her now there's no
evidence for this it's a comment that
she's just made but there's actually no
evidence for this what do you have to
say about that Ali would you do you
agree with her sentiment or do you
disagree with it no of course not it's
you know she's maybe that will work with
low level TN like you know no no no it
would things you need to understand man
who's securing himself um you know
dealing with a woman or that behavior I
mean that just shows me instability like
it shows me that person that that
person's not stable to do random because
what is this playing games yeah I come
from a Jia and these kind of games are
played why because at the end of the day
islamically when you have a structure in
place when it comes to W Guardian a
protocol in place of getting to know
someone there is no games to be played
now when that element is taken out you
are in a game now when you're in a game
you have to play the game now that's why
her to me what will surprise me is when
I see Muslim woman following her the
kufar woman sadly we want Islam for them
we want guidance for them but because
they don't have that they have no choice
but to adopt those games because they're
already in the dirt so for them to come
out the dirt they have to play games and
mind tactics and this and that well find
it odd is when Muslim women have to go
and adapt these IDE ideas and if I do
this and if I do that you know if you're
dealing with that kind of men follow a
woman I I think you make a fantastic
Point actually because what she's
actually doing is she's giving women the
best advice yeah of how to get rid of if
like high value men high quality men
from their life yeah so this will this
will work if you're dealing with unres
men exactly so I'm saying if you're
dealing with this kind of men then
please follow her the issue is that you
know the truth is I actually believe you
can make an argument that what she's
saying will have the adverse effect for
her target audience because it will it
will definitely and I'll tell you
exactly why because of disrespect you
see a man who understands his own value
and he wants to be respected the more
respect he gets the more of a hero
complex he gets the more he wants her to
act more feminine the more benevolent
not benevolent the more generous he's
going to be in the way he actually acts
but when he feels that level of
disrespect then his reaction is not
going to be what she's telling people
she has no experience with this the
reaction is going to be like oh I don't
need her either exactly exactly so last
thing let's listen to the second part
because we've got a couple Clips here to
to listen to sprinkle sprinkle so even
if you ghost to to be single it doesn't
mean you're not dating it doesn't mean
you're not looking it doesn't mean
you're not having fun out there and
doing the most so when when they know
that you would rather be alone than deal
with them it also makes them upset and
they want you even more so they'll try
to come back and chase you they'll try
to come back and woo you they'll try
anything to get you back because they
know you know your value okay so on this
uh issue of chasing actually your this
is one of the key tenants of the female
red pill okay we're going to call this
now this kind of behavior this kind of
we're just going to call it the female
red pill we're going to call it that
call it the purple pill let's let's give
it a name let's give it a name the
purple pill because then you know if if
a person behaves in this manner say look
you're behaving in a purple pill manner
why don't I call it the dirty pink pill
no no purple pill is alliteration
something you can just before just
before we get into the chasing thing
what she said was quite disturbing it
doesn't mean you can't mess around it
doesn't mean you can look at yeah of
course of course I'm sorry that's that's
Street Behavior any girl that like she
doesn't care she for the streets and
she's talking about the girls on the
streets the thing is that type of
behavior and that type of culture it's
spreading so far so many times you see
this on online this person cheats on
that person that so what type of
sluttish behavior is she trying to
that's what she's trying to you need
understand she's they're they're dealing
with low tier men and now they getting
woman to devalue themel so they can meet
each other in a specific level that's
that's what she's prescribing you know
because woman you need to a woman that
actually likes a specific like a man um
she will do like there will be you know
woman communicates covertly but she will
still be doing some kind of indirect
chasing do you know what I'm trying to
say a woman who she's advising that
she's saying that oh let him chase you
or keep a distance those kind of women
those men are in the friend zone mhm
they not they not a woman that genuinely
lacks a man would find it very hard and
difficult to do keep him at bait like in
a sense where keep the distance because
she wants that man and she fears a woman
usually because of the hormones they are
already uh there's instability so for
example for her it's even worse to be
like okay I'm going to play uh mind
games and keep a distance because they
fear the the risk of losing that man if
he's you know I mean so this is
something that Agro mentioned in her
book why why men love and she
gives a very interesting analogy that
now a lot of people are using the same
kind of analogy which is that when a
hunter goes out and he gets you know um
whatever it is he hunts whatever he
hunts d for sake of argument uh the
chase okay um makes him very proud of
what his hunted that's why he sticks on
the wall etc etc proud of it now look I
here's what I want to say first and
foremost I don't think there's complete
falsehood in this statement of course
for example a woman who is groeling
desperate 100% a woman who's chasing
yeah a woman who's um you know showing
no self-respect I think that's
unattractive that's crosscultural bro
that happens with friends that happens
with the opposite woman man to woman
it's it's it's a crosscultural thing bro
I haven't done the studies on this but I
think I would probably be right in
thinking that if a woman is in that too
much in that direction that she would be
or even a man yeah even a man of course
a man yeah right yeah exactly but on the
other hand what she's what she's
describing here here can actually have
the same impact so in other words if
you're leaving too much of a distance
yes it can cause the same problem the
man may think that may interpret that as
disrespectful Behavior he may interpret
that as well she's not interested lack
of Interest and it's only a man with low
like you said low tear man it's a good
way low quality man who's going to start
chasing that's the first thing the
second thing I want to mention from our
perspective as Muslim men right uh there
is something in Islam
called and also these two concepts are
basically when a man for the process of
disciplining his wife would for example
you know give her the silent treatment
or go to another house or go you know
not not have engag with her intimately
Etc yeah the only the only allowance
that Islam allows for a man obviously
because there's a hierarchy here in
Islam for in that context is the
allowance where she's being nashes or
she's being rebellious now he has that
tool in his disposal here's what I want
to say is that if you ever if a man
Muslim man now because I think um this
is advice I would probably have
benefited from before I became married
and so on but if if a Muslim
man right is being treated like that by
his wife for no reason for no reason he
hasn't treated the the point the point
I'm making yeah for no reason I think
what she's trying to do is she's making
a power move on him and if he accepts it
he becomes submissive he actually become
he might have tangibly he might be
financially powerful tangibly he might
have all the all the infrastructure in
place all that kind of thing he might be
much more powerful than him from all
those perspectives but if she wins this
game she wins all the games she actually
becomes in control of that relationship
and only that she will not be attracted
to a husband you need to understand the
Dynamics between man and a woman is not
the same if if a woman this the reason
why honest with you I I highly do not
advise woman to get get advice from
other women I rather say to them to go
to women that are mature who have been
married who have who have some kind of
experience yeah you know you know Al you
made a very good point sometimes when
there's a change in someone's behavior
is due to their friends it's due to
their friends feeding certain
information into them and what we have
to realize is this type of information
that she's chucking on the internet
that's one of the problems of having
every everybody having access right is
destroying relationships like this is
the sort of thing that will destroy the
power dynamic because in any
relationship you have to have a
hierarchy you can't walk into an
organization and say everyone's the boss
no exactly and the boss has a specific
role to play so the thing is here is
when a woman when she's trying to get W
their husbands to submit or their
boyfriends to submit to the woman a
woman innately with her nature does not
like aanda submissive unless unless once
again we go for those men that we talked
about un
resilient then what happens is that if
that man is insecure when he succumbs to
that she's automatically already put off
so she's she's seeking something that's
going to cause a demise it's true let's
go for the third uh third clip you know
I thought you were 40 you look so young
what are you doing you know you must
work out build him up make him forget he
old then when you need to pull that
trigger pull
it well did they have telephones when
you were a little
boy so basically she's she's saying that
when you when the Ty build your man up
okay build them up give them craze give
them you know give them the the the
carrot you know give the incentive and
then when the time comes when you want
to manipulate him for your own needs
whatever it is then just humiliate him
so basically use uh Ultra praise and
Ultra humiliation as means of
manipulating where does this uh or where
have you read this before let's say this
is this is standard mavan understanding
this is standard gaslighting standard
way of manipulating people to get the
consequence that you actually want
what's so interesting about what she's
actually saying is what's the evidence
that any of this works because the thing
I was thinking about when she was
talking is what makes you think a man
doesn't know what you're doing exactly a
good exactly you know do you know what
is is this will work on a low IQ man it
might work on a low IQ man but the thing
is is that you are underestimating the
IQ of men one of the things in in an and
a standard IQ test that you're actually
you know if if you like tested for is
patent detection if a man starts see
yeah if a man starts seeing okay well
she's starting to give me the cold
treatment for no reason every time it's
pay time or or some other reason or
she's just doing it haphazardly or
arbitrarily do you not think any
decently intelligent man is going to
detect that and understand that you're
doing that well the thing is maybe she's
been running in the circles where you
have room temperature IQ which is why
maybe some of this stuff is actually
working but like you said any other
person would realize okay a game is
being played and they'll do a 4D chess
move like she doesn't even what I find
interesting is she's giving you one
tactic she's not telling you he may get
on to this or do this XY Z there's no
Napoleonic understanding you know do you
know how we started off by saying this
is very mackelli and very you know um
kind of like instrumentalist very
consequentialist and so on and so forth
yeah the truth of the matter is it's not
as ma manipulative as she wants it to be
and I'll explain why a true woman
manipulator I'm not trying to give
anyone advice no but being honest would
not mention finances at all she she
would not mention she would not be doing
things uh that can be easily telegraphed
it's basically she's she's telling women
to Telegraph every single one of her
punches so that the man can detect yeah
she she can detect exactly what you're
doing a true manipulator there's a
higher level of manipulation which is to
to leverage him with love and compassion
and all that kind of thing then if if
she does it like that then she's going
to get more out of him brilliant you
know the that guy the Tinder swindler
whatever he was called right one of the
things that's so powerful about these
types of scammers is that they would
build rapport by not telegraphing the
moves by actually spending on you
continuously and then you expected to
spend on them so it's a very
sophisticated hierarchy of getting
people confused through layers so
actually she's a weak and we have to
Define here what manipulation is because
I think one way you can say is you will
not be
manipulated if you are not emotional if
you're not triggered yeah okay so she's
trying to trigger and she actually has a
video of that title she's like how to
trigger a man or something like that
well I don't know what men you're you're
triggering honestly I think it's once
again low IQ men low quality men you can
trigger them what you like but this
shows you the importance for Muslim men
that are watching this that are getting
into relationships or non Muslim men as
well that benefit no problem that when
you get into a relationship okay when
you get into a relationship emotional
control okay not to be triggered not to
shout not to raise your voice not to get
violent not to this is the one of the
most important things a a man has to
know before to get into a relationship
if a woman has succeed if your wife has
succeeded in making you angry and act
uncharacteristically then you have lost
that's how she wins that's true I mean
like I think we need to just quickly
analyze also a bit about her because
there's there's a lot of things to be
said because firstly I believe with this
kind of woman who have dedicated their
whole entire Channel or the existence to
um how to control a man how to do that
you need to understand they come from
places of look every woman wants
stability every woman wants somebody
that they in their nature biologically
as well they they they have to procreate
they're the one who are in vulnerable
positions the hormones go up and down
they need somebody who can look after
them and um you know protect them and
women like these sadly what happens is
because they don't have a structure in
their life like Islam does that's given
to them to protect their rights and
protect their honor because they don't
have that they get violated they get
used and abused now when they get used
and abused that what happens is that
they turn in resentment now question I
want to ask is how old is our husband or
the daddy from I think he it might be
60s and 70s ask a simple question yeah I
think there's a huge difference ask a
simple question it's very simple it
makes perfect sense yeah okay would the
fact the fact that he's allowing her to
say all this
online look she's married to a low tier
man Aki let me tell you something yeah
appar got a lot of money though this guy
that's my point bro listen to me very
carefully yeah she is there talking
about man which well which who would
marry a woman who's clearly saying how
to violate another individual yeah as a
man number one number two it shows that
do you really think if you went to her
and said is is this your ideal man that
you married to she say no way in hell so
she is married to a man she does not
like who she is using which means that
she comes from a background of she had
an idealistic man which used her and
abused and CH you never know she could
love this man no brother genuinely a
woman a woman who marries a man at that
that age bro believe me she is with that
man for a specific reason okay and now
she's venting out because she never got
I think the evidence of that would be
the fact that she just keeps talking
about the fact that you go of and she is
venting out because the man she
genuinely wanted to she couldn't get and
when a woman settles down she is the
most dangerous and she is settled now
and settled means she has no choice but
to marry a old man that's a sugar daddy
that would just provide her lifestyle so
she can make Tik Tok videos about him
yes so to me it just shows that
she's disrespecting her own husband
video like it's
like exactly it shows that she has no
respect like it and to me to go to
someone like her and take any kind of
advice it is catastrophic I think I
think honestly one last thing I mention
is who would watch videos like this I
would say anybody that watches videos
like this that's fatherless Behavior
that's brotherless behavior only if you
don't have if you have weak men in your
family you have low IQ men you you have
low men from the perspective of G of
having protection jealousy only then
would you would you have women that go
around looking because look why is it
and this is something all of us have
probably experienced when talking to uh
our wives or whoever it is that whenever
there's a woman who comes from a good
family with her brother's protective her
uncle's protective her cousin's
protective her dad's protective that
woman is more feminine and doesn't
listen to this crap yes yes she knows
what queen treatment is bro because
she's been her brother her father's
looked after and the thing is I think we
have to take away from all of this is
that Islam encourages a system of
complimentarity okay of where the that
man and the woman is she she started off
by talking about the woman being a prize
and the red pill this is exactly the
language of The Red Pill by the way they
say the man is the prize in fact in the
rational male the the book you call it
the red pill book The Bible of the red
pill it says something of that of that
nature right and they all talk about
that the point is is that she's saying
that women have the prize there so she's
reversing what the red pill copy and
paste plagiarizing actually what they're
saying but for women this language is
all false why because the truth is a man
has something to gain from a woman and a
woman has something to gain from a man
so for for each other their prizes for
each other I know it sounds cliche to
say but if there wasn't a transactional
value that was outside of the the
material something to do with the
emotional aspect something to do with
the spiritual aspect something to do
with all of that kind of thing then men
and women would been getting together
for all of humankind that's the first
thing so I think the first thing we need
to understand is that the aim is
complimentarity Absolut that we complete
each other not to oppose one another
number one and number two is
authenticity at the end of the day stop
playing mind game stop trying to adopt
these techniques stop trying to you know
instead of all this just be open honest
authentic and the good quality men that
you want in your life you'll find those
good quality men recognizing that in you
yeah okay and then you you'll be in a
better place otherwise keep continue
doing this stuff and you'll find exactly
what you're looking for and it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy you start
playing those silly games that person
I'm sorry to say people are going to
refute me for this some women may not
like me saying this but when it comes to
manipulation the man if he wants to get
into that he'll play games which are far
more sophistic
so if it's going to be like okay so you
want to play these games okay they're
just going to start playing way more
sophisticated sophisticated games cuz
this woman like I said before what is
she doing she is simply giving you a ABC
level of manipulation which is just do
this little thing yeah there's no
counter counter to this plan Plan B what
happens if this happens or or or um if
if he comes back with this particular
attack how do you do the nothing it's
just stick to this plan yeah just be a
high quality woman in and a a man a
decent man would find you I mean it's as
simple as that you know if you're going
to follow This Woman's advice she going
to be sprinkle sprinkle over your
graveyard on that we will
conclude hey you are you wasting your
time on social media again your brothers
and sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more